okay so we
okay he just went Knight D4
I'm gonna look like a genius and I'm
going to look pretty blank at the end of
this but hold on come on Rook takes D4
hold on hold on Knight D4 is on the
board chance to make a winning exchange
sack well winning is like at least well
we're hoping this move uh but uh did you
know the last few moves Ian has been
blitzing
yes he didn't bother with the he didn't
even consider Bishop G6 yeah because we
thought that was a real Fortress element
yeah let's quite Bishops he didn't
bother with uh and he just charged up to
D4 and I think Rook d484 Knight B3 how
are you evaluating this for me it looks
overwhelming look at ding look at that
posture that's the posture of someone
who who sees something and is trying to
figure it out
right yes yes Bingo it's over wow hold
on game over I think ding just went for
it so the exchange sack and nipple looks
a little bit surprised it looks a little
bit taken aback by that but he's got to
have seen mag B3 now sure and Knight B3
so is the point and basically your night
well if you get the pawn and you get
your knight in here then it's definitely
the game over well things walking away
yeah things walking away
um yeah feeling pretty good about his
position